يجب أن أتحدث عن موضوع واحد وموضوع واحد
فقط وهو الصراع في الشرق
الأوسط أه أه الفظائع التي
تحدث منذ
7 أكتوبر أه نحتاج إلى وضع حد لها أه
يعني أكثر من 30 ألف شخص ماتوا 60  %
منهم أطفال ونساء وأه 85%
من الناس تم تهجيرهم في غزة
أكثر من 2 مليون شخص تم تدمير جميع المستشفيات
يعني هذه الأشياء أه
يجب أن تنتهي أه لا ينبغي أبدا أن
نسمح بقتل المدنيين الأبرياء
أشعر بالأسف على الأمريكان لأن  لقد كنت في
كل مكان منذ 7 أكتوبر، في الشرق
الأوسط وآسيا ونيوزيلندا في كل مكان
والتغطية هنا متحيزة تمامًا
وأقصد أن أكون منصفًا، فإن
زعماء العالم يخذلوننا والشيء الوحيد الذي
يمكننا فعله هو الضغط على
الرأي العام لدينا و  تثقيف أنفسنا أم
لأن هذا يجب أن ينتهي وينتهي اليوم
وليس
غدا